This would be the proper forehand grip.
As you can see, the racket is pointing downwards rather than flat.
And this would be the proper backhand grip, with my thumb on the flat end of the racket.
To start, if you're right-handed, put your right hand on the racket face...
...and from there, slide the racket down until you hit the grip.
Close it with the first three fingers.
Put your thumb above the middle finger...
...and your hand should now form a "V" with the racket grip.
It's very similar to shaking somebody's hand as you're holding this racket right now.
With the forehand grip,...
...it allows you to get into proper position as you turn out the racket...
...and swing with your wrist,...
...without anything blocking or hurting your wrist.